my name is Jana salio I am vice
president of the information will
unfriend on religion and paste and I
deeply concerned on good education
especially victim of how to build
tolerance among you too because what we
will see man went and internalization is
like a ceremony of religion so delicious
experian and knowing at this vertex
ready game it's a part of utility most
important nutrient solution especially
in a million people live with the
bellows additional belong to different
regions and how we see that do not abuse
in four people in terrorism draymond
elements and so on but I studied it less
we can build really good relationship
with your understanding among use if
they can open up experience through
knowing others in very simple way I
propose for example let's organize
something smaller like physically others
were house of worship and do them ask
them what they are doing and what does
all mean together and do its visual
person from one group to another it is
the one way we can come boats what you
are understanding and with a relation in
the more relatives